and judy are you interested in i have a  parrot  yes  yes yes yes because i was given a parrot  at christmas really yes this is news to  me a ch charming  charming parrot called sweetheart  and she's lived with a man  charming's lived 14 years 14 years yes  now she's come to me  i said to david who brought her to me  does she speak  and he said oh yes she'll speak all  right and she goes  what are you doing  what are you doing about half past 11 in  the morning she says bedtime  but i've tried you know being very  refined and hoping that she might do a  bit of to be or not to be i do repeat  that a lot just goes  she goes  looks at me sideways bedtime  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you